and ultimately and finally by the New
York Jets win six Super Bowls and then
die
you got your perspective
[Music]
[Music]
so for people coming through I had a
really fun day on vacation we're selling
baseball cards on on Twitter and like
the kicker was I can come and pick it up
so obviously people are buying it just
cuz that it was really fun to meet that
kid like when I when I entered college I
had such a bad mindset yeah because I
was like you know I don't really want to
be here I just won't work yeah but like
listening to a podcast every day having
like positivity in my ears has really
just like helped me along it was really
thought it was an opportunity to kind of
create a clarity here I think I think
what's really tough about putting out
content the internet for all us creators
and content producers is some people
just consume one video or one time or
you've got a subtle message that even
yourself you're not doing a great job
communicating on and that's what I'm
kind of trying to do here I put so much
pressure on college my thesis isn't like
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and and so much so
that I think the subtleties of my
biggest macro which is like look on the
Brightside glasses half-full make the
best of your situation in no matter what
the situation is is far greater than my
concern that collecting debt in college
is not setting you up for financial
success post college you know for
example you could be collecting debt
like that young man is I don't know if
we can get to that as you can see in the
video but let's say he is him going into
college or the next three and a half
years with a positive mindset may lead
to him meeting somebody who becomes
their you know like it's offense he
meets some youth Seth Seth becomes
friends with him Seth gets into Boehner
he set then gets him into Vayner sets
the cool I mean people get it when
you're positive when you're happy
you it's it's not fluffy [ __ ] it's
not like oh you're drinking the kool-aid
it's being practical to understand that
yes always beats no
that son always beats rain that
positivity always beats anger and people
get confused because anger and negative
and doing the wrong thing actually has
short-term results if me Seth and Caleb
go rob a jewelry store tonight and don't
get caught we got a bunch of [ __ ]
jewelry but it now becomes the
vulnerability because the second time we
may get caught because I promise you you
don't rob a jewelry store just once and
if you understood what I just said
you're on your way
love I love when people you know like to
me it's just the truth like you know to
me I don't think I don't think I'm nice
or a prick or anything I think I just I
think it's really a good idea about talk
if you talk about the truth it puts you
in a in a position of strength yeah you
know as you know you know now hearing
your story the advantages and their
substantial the advantages that you and
I had is that you know immigrant
families have such context for all the
opportunity so it's hard for them to
complain about dumb [ __ ] Americans born
here to abundance complain about dumb
[ __ ] and by the way I'm not like you
[ __ ] idiots I'm like that's your
situation you didn't know you didn't
know I always see if you're born in this
country
you got a Social Security number you
don't go to aspire to the top of that
building oh they're shooting candy
issues I look at people like I know
people aren't here right otherwise
they're aspiring right well but here's
where you and I one people born in this
country have lots of money in the bank
but have parents that don't create the
blueprint that leaves them to success
here yeah you've mentioned it it's a
legacy dude it's this yeah it's a
mindset game it's the operating system
people understand like if your operating
system your phone is fuck'd you can't
use it's this garbage but they don't
understand when this is [ __ ] like I
just think yes is powerful you know an
improv never say no I always say yes and
and to me the know players of our
friends were like focus focus focus
they're like look look how successful I
was I focus I'm like cool I said yes and
was helter skelter I'm successful yeah
like I think a lot of this comes down to
self-awareness yeah you know I think
when you can accept yourself you know
and for me you said a very subtle thing
in there that once you learned that you
have to accept it as a net game yeah
that those you know for every Ben's
meeting that led to amazing things with
Pinterest there was six others that led
to nothing absolutely or a waste of time
or an awkward situation or things that
you didn't want to deal with you know
just
it's part of the game a lot of my
mistakes helped me get better at the
nose in a world where I want to say yes
to everything
hi you guys ready
[Music]
why we are here is very simple nine
years ago my brother and I wanted to
start a company the opportunity we saw
at hand was in the advertising agency
world but it was to be a gateway to
everything else we ever did somewhere in
my late 20s early 30s I realized that
even though I suck at most things my
ability to understand human beings and
communicate to them was strong and
intuitively I understood what humans
were gonna do oftentimes before the
masses it's why I invested in things
that went on to become big things it's
why in 1996 I launched an e-commerce
wine business
to sell wine everything good in my life
marrying my wife one second into our
first conversation everything good in my
life has been predicated on my ability
to understand human behaviors slightly
before the rest that was the mission a
veiner X that continues to be the
mission of Vayner X and that will
forever be the mission of interacts how
do we build something that communicates
to solve a problem at scale whether that
is to sell sneakers or wine or beer or
telco or whatever it is or as I get
older in my years to get Husain to be
the Governor of California or to cure
Crohn's disease or anything else and
ultimately and finally buy the New York
Jets win six Super Bowls and then die
[Music]
this is where we're going so I'm excited
thank you thank you for your attention
it's going well against Eliot Kelly I
just wanted to personally tell you thank
you so much for the opportunity
watching you your company very long time
I come from a simple household on East
Orange New Jersey to Newark yet is
really hard to even have somebody so you
know just in there I really appreciate
the environment and the culture I
appreciate that I really thank you thank
you so much
yeah I'm looking for to get to know you
better man yeah yeah man hit me up
anytime thank you saying that the studio
residence on 11th November I have the
opportunity you make sure you email me
before that ends I'm dead serious
you got it
[Music]